what is the last time you've broken up
with someone over something like what
was the ick or like stopped going on
dates with someone mine has been for
communication I can't deal with somebody
that doesn't communicate well with me I
just wanted to know if if what I'm
saying you actually feel that it is
stupid or you agree with what I'm saying
there needs to be some sort of
understanding if there if we haven't
come down to a decision of yeah you're
being over like over the top how is you
coming across sometimes it's not what
you say it's how you say it's how you
deliver it yeah and sometimes a lot of
women very Agy and bit we don't approach
it correctly that is another thing that
is another thing it is how you um
approach it